tonight's opening face off brought to you by
Simpson Chevrolet the referees are Kevin Pollock
loved him in The Usual Suspects and Mitch Dunning
the linesman are Matt mcferson and Julian forier
we are underway and glad to have you along on a
Wednesday night they've got a real good power play
this season it has been carrying them at times
so discipline is going to play a huge role in the
outcome tonight interesting to see how the Ducks
new line combinations affect the offense they've
been able to find quite a bit of it on the road
opportunity I was just talking about it comes off
of a offensive zone face off and Clayton ker is
so elusive just throws it towards the net and you
Coyote's coming off an 8-1 shellacking of Chicago
at home on Monday they are riding High a lot of
players had big Point nights in that game puck
rimmed around the boards Terry seals the the wall
brings it in lets it go he scores Troy Terry on
the power play the Ducks break the ice this comes
out of nothing and and you know the whole key here
it's a self chip by mikov on the entry into the
Zone here's mikov here's the Chip And he follows
it up and here's the pressure so the coyotes
react to that pressure hard Rim Troy Terry's got
space he says thanks very much he'll take it and
he just rips it up top short side over top of the
blocker what a perfect shot by Troy Terry Anheim
had nothing going on and then Anaheim will have
a minute and 39 of Power Play Time Dumba bumped
oh nice play by mikov who took him out of the play
and took the puck back now three on two Here Come
the Ducks drop pass to Fowler back to mikov oh
he hit the goal post rebound score Terry has his
second of the night I thought mck initially scored
but good on Troy Terry who stayed with it it's two
nothing it starts with him making an unbelievable
defensive play gets a great angle and look at him
turn it up realize that Dumba had dropped a
stick not only does he drop the puck but he
continues going towards the net he hits the pipe
Terry mops it up for his second of the game but I
tell you what pav mikov what a beautiful play
by him and good on Troy Terry Michael carcone
didn't even chase that pass he just headed back
to the Arizona bench carcone had a hat trick on
Monday against the Blackhawks Fowler collects
behind his own net and is met by Lawson Krauss
Moser moves it to the top of the Zone gets it
back right in front great pass and Krauss is
there to put the desert dogs on the board big
Winger for the coyotes big powerful kid watch
this puck off a skate but boy Moser does a great
job of taking that puck off the skate right there
and then tapping it across to Lawson Krauss for
the one timer and lome gloves it down and moves
it up McTavish contested and has it taken away
there good play by Moser dery indirectly moves
it ahead didn't connect with kolie but here he is
now behind the defense Logan kolie scores first
NHL goal for Logan kie and the coyotes of it's
tied at two good Puck movement Moser again makes
the play kie does a good job of protecting that
puck from Jackson lol see him stick that left leg
out the coyotes have now scored nine first period
goals in their last three games combined this is a
team that coming into tonight's game is averaging
just under three and a half goals a game here's
vodan n and kidding went right into the goal
crease popped up in the air silverberg had a
poke at it and Vela will smother while we hear
this from Hyundai now it's schaltz and Keller
into the Anaheim Zone disrupted at the Blue
Line and out as vrono gets it ahead here's
Bo Gru short-handed bucker Sav Mela in a penalty
killing roll and ogu back into the lineup he and
now it's the Coyote's turn to get to all these
loose machell hands it off balamaki peels back
at the top of the circle again machell trying
to penetrate the middle of the ice forced wide
by bakan in front and they score Lawson Krauss
again the big body spins off of his check and back
hands it up top the coyotes have a 3-2 lead lus
was not happy watch the front of the net Krauss
and gutus there's the cross check that knocks
gutus down to the ice and no call on the play
and there's no way that he
can get to that rebound as a
result and he's going to be a great ad you
know get a veteran player who can you know
help your power play help your penalty kill be
a physical force all of those attributes and and
some leadership as well color will bring to the
table looks over at Troy Terry has it knocked
off his stick and Lookout cookout Alexander
KERO shorthanded comes in dostall makes the
save and on the back check and applies pressure
to kerfoot and that makes life easier for the
goenda to the right of Carell Vela and kolie off
the glass but not out steered over Gus Rolling
Puck right on rebound shovel on then on the
backhand by Carlson got his own rebound back
Terry SC [Music] Carlson in front along with Jones
and this game is tied who have come out here and
have controlled play to begin this third period
there's the shot yeah it's off the shaft of the
Stick of Leo Carlson off the defenseman off the
shaft of the sck it's a double deflection and
it's perfect up into the top corner so for Leo
his third of the season in just his sixth game
and the ducks have tied things up as McTavish
and zis get the puck back in the Arizona Zone
and McTavish a little too fancy a drop pass in the
high slot intended for vrono now Keller the other
way hands it off Barrett hating robbed by the
left pad of doall playing well not only do you
make good stops like this one on Barrett Hatton
but also seems sometimes you get the brick breaks
too there's the left leg extended across stetcher
throws it to the middle of the ice here's schaltz
trying to go short side doall said no another
pick down low Schwartz hits schz hits the post
Ducks all tied up nobody can get a stick fore to
play it here's the break I was referencing aalt
spun and he just whipped that high block Keller's
pass off the skate of silverberg zigris gets it to
the line dermit kept it in a Rolling Puck that's
blocked stetcher keeps it up the boards that'll do
it the horn [Applause] sounds kind of a yogiism if
you will but you know the the early season games
mean as much as the late season games so the Ducks
win the all important face off to begin overtime
Terry with minakov out there and Carlson Keller
gets the puck back and now circles high with
schaltz back to Keller looking for a shooting Lane
blocked by Leo Carlson who's pucking the corner
schaltz ran into the referee mnov plays it around
Carlson ahead breakway for Troy Terry oh tried to
go five hole Thea stopped him what a stop three
on three here he comes Cuts in front poke check
do got to go they had a man Advantage
here got to go Mavis now turns it into
a two-on-one with Terry Mason Mavis
to Terry score hatrick overtime game
winner